good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
7819 object class ker
uncontained special containment
procedures if you are currently under
the influence of SCP 7819 please
immediately refer to addendum 1
SCP 7819 is still under active study if
you believe you have come into contact
with it contact the research lead
immediately description SCP 7819 is a
predatory location that manifests along
exits of the United States numbered
highway system in the contiguous United
States SCP 7819 appearance is generally
fixed it presents as a small roadside
Hotel or motel though the exact layout
may vary advertising vacant rooms always
identified by exterior signage as the
rest easy in several conditions must be
met for SC SCP 7819 to manifest for a
driver the time between midnight and
4:00 a.m. local time zone the driver of
the vehicle must have been driving for
over 5 hours discounting small brakes
the driver must be a past or present
Foundation employee the driver must be
alone in the
vehicle upon driving near SCP 7819 the
driver will begin to feel a deep-seated
sense of fatigue and tiredness it is
unclear whether this is a natural
reaction to driving for several hours
and seeing an opportunity for a break or
an anomalous phenomenon caused by SCP
7819 to lure drivers in regardless this
fatigue will continue as the driver
pulls off the highway and into the
parking lot of the in should the driver
drive past SCP 7819 the sense of fatigue
will remain though through unknown means
their vehicle will be seamlessly
transported several miles backward often
without their
realization they will drive past SCP
7819 again be transported backward again
and this process will continue until
they park inside of CP
7819 the driver will not be able to
escape this phenomenon until they exit
their vehicle enter SCP 7819 and perform
several requisite
activities these activities vary but SCP
7819 many manifestations have provided a
relatively Dependable action plan for
performing the rituals and surviving SCP
7819 if you are currently under the
influence of SCP 7819 please proceed
through addendum 1 remain calm and do
not rush accuracy and efficiency is more
important for survival than
speed good
luck addendum 1 SCP 7819 Survival Guide
up to date to March 26th
1996 space parking
lot
instructions bring your car into an
empty parking space try to select one
that's surrounded by other vehicles to
separate yourself from the pack would
attract attention once you park exit
your vehicle take only what you need
whatever device you are reading or
listening to this document on your
cellular phone Keys purse or wallet and
a bag containing some toiletries and
Essentials luggage and clothing will
slow you down if you have been equipped
with a firearm or own one privately do
not take it with you spend some time in
the parking lot before entering the
lobby observe the other parked cars
around you you will note inconsistencies
such as wheels made of wood unclear
jumbles where logos and brand marks
should be and shapes or designs that do
not correspond to any actual Vehicles
produced by Automotive
companies avoid looking through the
windows if there is a large burning
vehicle in the parking lot do not
investigate it further if at all
possible pretend it is not there enter
the lobby before the fire goes
out I followed protocol pulled my
Forerunner into a parking spot of this
dingy sex Motel the last parking spot
actually the lot was completely full
otherwise I grab a few things I have and
squeeze out of my car parked next to
this big dodge Caroline except wait no
I'm not
it's like you described a caravan to
someone else and they described it to
someone else and then that person had to
make a model of what they had in mind
out of
papier-mâché I accidentally knocked a
hand against it and realized that it was
made out of some kind of plaster and it
was
Hollow I got curious so I started
investigating the other cars all like
this Locos and designs that look like
cars on you going up but took a closer
look and it's all nonsense a facade
literally I wasn't scared or anything
but it did put me on edge like how when
you know someone is trying to put you at
ease you put your hackles
up space
Lobby
instructions upon entering the lobby
make your way to the front
desk it will be unoccupied
you may ring the bell once if the sound
brings you
comfort wait in the lobby without
exiting it hum your favorite song to
yourself as you wait the silence in the
lobby has been described as oppressive
stop humming when you become aware of
the noises coming from behind the
counter hop the counter there should be
a closed door rattling as though someone
is on the other side listen to the
sounds and note them down when they get
louder repeatedly slam your fist against
the
door do not
speak eventually you will be slipped a
key to a room this may not work on the
first attempt repeat it until you
succeed say thank you and
depart no idea what's going on door's
firmly locked I can just hear through it
and the paper thin walls pretty filthy
noises soft enough to where I have to
press my ear against the door to hear
anything wet slapping like someone
stumping a drenched towel against the
ground over and
over there's this periodic wet coughing
the slapping stops during the
coughing also this
moan it sounds in pain like someone
starving to death Rises and falls in
Pitch but it's always there I can hear
Whispering too
and sometimes the moaning and whispering
and coughing are all at the same
time how many people are in
there I tried rattling the door knob and
it all stopped all of it except for the
moany I froze and after a few seconds
they went back into it weird as
space
elevator
instructions your room will be
inevitably on on a higher floor and you
will be unable to find stairs forcing
you to use the elevator you will notice
that the buttons are in an inexplicable
pattern and have unclear writing on them
press whichever one feels right there
will never be another person in the
elevator with you if you see
someone be aware that they are not
human treat them with the appropriate
level of caution do not remove your eyes
from them
and always stand with your back against
a
wall if the figure resembles an older
cleancut man wearing an expensive suit
and Overcoat do not enter the elevator
it will smile at you complement your
appearance and hold the door for you it
will do this for up to several minutes
repeatedly attempting to convince you to
enter politely but firmly tell it that
you are just passing through and and
will wait for the next one stand beyond
the threshold it cannot pursue you
outside of the elevator eventually it
will move
on if the figure resembles a middle-aged
woman in hiking gear you may enter the
elevator and ride it to your destination
the elevator ride will take much longer
than it should up to half an
hour do not
panic and reciprocate the woman's
attempts to make convers ation do not be
honest with her lie openly and brazenly
about every possible detail including
obvious ones such as your ethnicity and
age she appreciates this if the figure
resembles a younger vagrant it is safe
to enter the elevator they will not
speak but may offer you a hug accepting
this has no consequences and is left to
your discretion when you arrive at at
your floor they may offer a small
trinket such as a tin duck or ceramic
ashtray accept it gratefully and keep it
close at
hand my nerves are on fire I was lucky I
pulled the vagrant card instead of the
Wall Street angler fish cart at least
May seemed nice couldn't have been older
than 19 or 20 dressed in clothes
completely worn
through I got in and we were standing
next to each other heading up to my
floor when he reached out I just sort of
let it happen and he hugged me a proper
hug haven't been hugged like that in a
long time didn't say a word just hugged
me for a few seconds like he knew I
needed it stepped back handed me a
matchbox filled with leaves and then the
doors were closing and he was
gone space
hallways instructions you will exit out
of the elevator into a hallway of some
kind checking your room key is
pointless it will either not have a room
number or have an entirely impossible
one your room will make itself known to
you when you find it as such begin
walking down the
hallway resist the urges to investigate
the other rooms in the hallway the doors
have pee Poes in them and making eye
contact May invite unwelcome attention
keep your eyes focused Focus down and
ignore any feelings of being observed as
you proceed down the hall avoid making
noise the other guests are
sleeping the hallway is generally not
linear and you may find various other
spaces eventually you will arrive at a
Crossroads these will occur regardless
of whether the exterior topology of SCP
7819 allows for it and are suspected to
be in conru
spaces as such it is advised not to
remain in them for more than a few
minutes at most Personnel who have died
in The Crossroads report dull headaches
and paranoia this is best addressed by
picking a direction at random and
beginning to walk down it it is unclear
whether SCP 7819 adapts to one's mind or
vice versa but this has been the most
effective method for arriving at one's
room you will know it when you see
it I have no idea how long I was walking
at least 40 minutes but that was after I
started checking my
watch just endless Shad carpet and
flickering yellow lighting and shitty
Commercial Art on the
walls I thought it would just be one
long hallway but it wasn't I mean it's
fast it was but then it ended and took a
sharp right turn and then a left and
then down a set of stairs pass a sling
Lounge through a little
walkway didn't have any sense of
consistency to the construction just
felt like a weird amalgamation of every
Hotel I've ever been in glued together
without
thought eventually it started getting
really bizarre the carpet went from drag
Bays to like the pattern you find on bus
seats there were curtains but they were
nailed to the wall so they couldn't be
open every successive set of doors kept
getting lifted a few inches off the
ground until they were literally halfway
into the
ceiling this isn't a place people were
meant to
be Space
Room
instructions use your key and enter your
room you will immediately feel a
chillness in the
air this is
normal do not close the door behind you
until you have turned on all the lights
and ensured you are alone in the room
there may be a door to an adjoining room
move a piece of furniture in front of
this door or otherwise find a way to
barric the layout of the room will vary
and be completely
idiosyncratic such as having mismatched
furniture sets dozens of chairs filling
the room with nothing else or being
difficult to Traverse do your best to
get comfortable the bathroom may be
locked from the inside but this is not a
point of concern unless you have reason
to believe someone is
inside if you
do bar the door to the best of your
ability you may keep the lights on or
dim them but get into a bed and pull the
covers over yourself if the room has a
television you may put something on to
calm your nerves Personnel have
suggested Home and Garden television
delivers the best
results eventually you you will fall
asleep my room had three beds standing
out from and facing a single focal point
a shitty microwave that wasn't even
plugged in absolutely baffling like it
was designed by a person with no
understanding of how humans
lived I got in and made sure everything
was fine then put my stuff down took a
leak which is when I found out the
bathroom was fake the plumbing wasn't
detached in the toilet and shower were
made out of like plywood like props on a
movie set hardly the weirdest thing so
far but for some reason it just fcked
with me I got out and slipped into bed
almost immediately I felt insanely tired
despite the
circumstances I could barely keep my
eyes open and right as I was drifting
off it occurred to me that I hadn't
checked under the
bench space pool
instructions you will wake up in the
hotel hot tub there will be no one else
in the indoor pool area and you will
feel physically awake but mentally
exhausted this is
normal a small radio set on a nearby
table may be playing a song from your
childhood but the signal will be of poor
quality try to tune it better if you can
but do not change the
station do not change the
station you may exit the Hun tub and
inspect the main pool it will generally
be of idiosyncratic shape and
construction you will find that the
surface tension of the water is much
stronger it has formed a thick tight
membrane that prevents objects from
breaking through it as such do not step
into the
water you will
drown underneath the membrane you may
see shapes moving
around ignore
them return to the hot tub re-entering
it this time completely submerge
yourself despite your expectations once
you go under it will not feel warm it
will feel painfully bitingly cold as
though stepping into ice water ignore it
and open your eyes you will find that
the hot tub descends several feet deeper
than expected
swim to the bottom and grab the small
object you see lying on the
floor inspect it after emerging from the
water you will find your clothes neatly
folded on a nearby
table try and redress yourself before
departing for your
room I've always loved hotel pools
something about them I don't know you'd
think everyone would go for it but for
whatever reason it feels like I'm the
only one who's ever in one
so it's just a nice calming space for me
to sink into the water and be utterly
alone this wasn't like that this felt
wrong in some interminable Indescribable
way every facet of it seemed designed
for maximum
discomfort the echo bouncing off the
ceiling and water being close enough to
your own voice to trick you up the
Angles and Contours of the pool were
unnatural like someone had never seen a
pool before literally hundreds of Life
preservers hanging off the walls the
main pool was
unnerving the membrane on top made it so
that everything underneath the surface
was blurry and hard to make out but
still I could see three or four blurry
shapes moving around swimming back and
forth one of them was person
shaped at first I thought it was another
person trapped or something and tried to
get a little closer didn't step into the
water but I put my hand against the
film they It Slam up on the other side
and pressed its Palm where mine was held
it there for a moment then it starts
slamming its fists against the M brain
wildly trying to tear through it like a
wild animal I can hear it screeching
from under the
water I screamed scrabbled backward
grabbed my things and ran thankfully I
only checked out the other pool after
getting the object from the hot toe it
was my engagement
ring my engagement ring I lost it years
ago flashed it down the toilet of a
hotel I was staying
[Music]
at space breakfast
area
instructions on your way back to your
room you will pass by the breakfast area
attached to the lobby despite it being
still night outside it will be open and
the lights
on
enter there will be a large amount of
food lay down on the counters most of it
will be inedible in some form though
there are usually some edible food
stuffs ignore all of them do not feel
guilty about doing so and instead make
your way to the only other person in the
breakfast
area join them at their table as they
eat they will attempt to persuade you to
stay
politely but firmly deny them it will
make your heart hurt but it is necessary
should you wish to
leave they will repeatedly do this and
you must repeatedly deny them until they
stop
asking plastic fruit styrofoam waffles
muddy water instead of coffee I'm not
exaggerating it was literally fake food
all laid out and presented like a
typical continental breakfast very weird
but I followed the instructions ignored
all of it and headed for the man at the
table older guy salt and pepper hair
looks like every dad the only sound in
the room was his chewing and the dead
air on the television as it softly
played
stattic he seemed excited to see me once
he noticed me asked me to please take a
seat so I did opposite him started
bombarding me with questions
where was I from where was I going how
long I'd been on the road but not with
the Sinister edge of the people in the
elevator genuine sincere wanting to know
if I was all right in having a nice time
I tried my best not to feel bad about
ignoring all of his questions and just
saying I want to leave I got the sense
he'd heard this a lot and he was
persistent about it what can I do to
make your stay better sorry I say but I
want to
leave you're not enjoying the the
amenities they're fine I still want to
leave don't you think this is nicer than
having to deal with the Troubles of life
it's a resort maybe but I prefer the
troubles over whatever this is fighting
to joke down the parts of me saying he
has a
point eventually he just goes Crest
Fallen is there anything else I can do
to make you stay no he seemed to accept
that told me to spend the rest of my
night check out in the morning
he was still sitting there when I left
alone space
checkout
instructions when you wake up the next
morning late regardless of when you fell
asleep gather your things and depart
your
room you will find that the layout of
SCP 7819 has shifted
dramatically and is much easier to
navigate several doors of in the hallway
will be hanging open and you will pass
cleaning carts as though housekeeping is
doing their
rounds there will be no one around
except you head to the elevators and
back down to the
lobby there will similarly be no one at
the front desk but place your key
down depart SCP
7819 get in your vehicle the parking lot
will now be empty and get back onto the
highway
driving until you can get into contact
with your nearest site and report your
SCP 7819
encounter the light of day makes things
feel a lot different the Labyrinth of
the carpet and hallway just felt odd now
not Sinister I went downstairs turned my
key into the empty desk the breakfast
area was closed again I stepped out the
doors the Sun was shining got in my car
got back on I 10 put the hotel in my
rear view mirror and then as soon as it
came it was gone my parents and I used
to take a lot of road trips when I was a
kid so we stayed in a lot of motels you
know the kind shitty roadside lodging
where the rooms are cramped and the
prices are dirt cheap years old carpet
unfashionable furniture from the' 70s
sinks that stick out into the room and
hard mattresses
not a resort just a place to lay your
head down for the night transitory
spaces where you're meant to come and go
not to stick around motels are not home
obviously they try their best to feel
like they're home but not particularly
well which is why they have such a
unique Vibe of their own a corporate
design space calculated to put you at
ease there are spaces for humans to
inhabit but there's there's nothing
really human about them 7819 embodies
that pretty well something that doesn't
really understand humans trying
fruitlessly to lure them in with
fractured memories of motel rooms and
hot tubs I don't know I don't know what
7819 is really I can only make guesses
from what I experien like I said I took
a lot of road trips as a kid and there
are some deeply deeply strange things
that live on the edges of these
highways if you follow these
instructions you will exit with no
issue if you
haven't we do not blame you for
staying
[Music]
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
zaran Big sip o crap guy James Sava
Irish
wwatch Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazaon worthy fire cobster Dean
dingis th loser braded Peach Ruan
O'Brien
Grim extra Ms 123 Swift raw ardu
malas Big Booty Judy Desmond kin and
oscuro
vision if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slth vulgan thank
you